you were always the king of fist-bump
you are the one that really brought
fist-bumped into the forefront are you
now going back to fist bump or are you
now completely no social distancing you
can't fist bump from six feet there are
no reason to touch isn't this good guys
good
I like this I'm happy with this me too
I'm at home with the people I love I'm
honest I'm sad I'm still on TV from the
comfort of my own home yeah I think what
we need to practice in this pandemic is
something that we need to practice each
and every day of our lives and that is
caring and empathy and reaching out one
of the people how he has reached out to
is Heidi Klum his fellow America's Got
Talent judge a few weeks ago it was
revealed that she and her husband were
being tested for kovin 19 after they
came down with flu-like symptoms and
thankfully both ended up testing
negative now she's back to health
Berner husband are not quarantined from
each other anymore so they're back
together and she's at home with her kids
and you know launching her her new show
on Amazon so she's she's healthy and and
I'm happy for that I was worried for a
while how is how is Sophia how's the
dynamic with Sophia o-m-g Sophia I
didn't know I've never met her before
but sitting be sitting on the same panel
Sophia you have no idea how funny she is
and and knowingly funny smart funny like
a whip and beautiful and and and really
has years and years of experience in
this business she when people watch this
season of AGT I mean I don't know that
we've ever had a better panel how he
tells us that 75 percent of this
season's AGT auditions were completed
before the kovat shut down and now
hopefuls can audition online for judges
as for what how he is doing in his spare
time well he's found out he's got a
brand new talent of his own there is a
video I saw where are you like the Baby
Whisperer now is that the thing
I put it up on my Instagram but it's
it's somebody else's ticked off I think
people think that that's my grandchild
it's nobody that I know but when the
baby's crying when they show them an
image of me they just stop crying I
don't know what's going on in the baby's
head maybe by looking at me they think
hey things could be worse you know and
that's kind of comforting but what a
great I'm the baby whisperer now you are
yes and before I let you go everybody
now is they're all working from home
everybody zooming in on meetings
everybody looks good up top but it's
what you have down below are you matched
right now okay you wearing nice pants
right now or you wait wait wait wait but
look at me well this is you I was amazed
you're in your are you in your home I'm
in my I'm in the home office yes yeah so
why put on a sports jacket you're a I
don't know you're not fooling anybody I
know I know and I debate okay you know
what here just wait wait wait let me
yeah he just didn't know I feel the
dalish now I think you look if you look
at me I'm wearing a t-shirt so what do
you say my matching below yeah I'm just
wearing sweatpants yeah I'm not I didn't
dress up for this show
[Music]